divertente
[Musica]
ciao ragazzi oggi sono qua per lavorare
visto facendo vedere quanto è difficile
fare il lavoro dello youtube
arezzo
c'è molta ma molta più gente l'anno
scorso perché come stanno a differenza
degli altri e 3
e aperto al pubblico nel senso che la
gente può entrare e pagando il biglietto
di poiché in suite solo che il biglietto
per le tre corsa tipo mille dollari
noi siamo noi ovviamente non abbiamo
pagato perché noi siamo lavoratori
siamo
marino
siamo arrivati finalmente la nintendo
ragazzo mi ha messo una vita perché
quando si cammina più da quando è aperto
al pubblico perché costa mille euro il
biglietto ma l'hanno comprato tutti non
si sa come siamo da nintendo dove circa
due anni fa ho fatto il video con il
doppiatore di supermario
ma la partita
bello premendo il tasto
mini premuto
ora come come come non solo la patente e
meritata più
massei di investire 1
ricordiamo gli avvisi in strada
[Musica]
no no non saprai mai cosa c'è la gloria
finito il tempo va dai quanto e meloni
guardarla
possibile che non la fa perché no meno
tanto j
la mia ragazza
la vita vinto così la casa
i miei zero morti
800 partite ho vinto
ragazzi ho incontrato di voi doppiatore
di mario e adesso proverò a dire la
frase che lui dice niente
nel gioco e poi lui dice quella seria
roma entra
liberi ma i suoi prey magari yacht
master
questa nuova mamma mamma
i ragazzi proviamo a fare un editing in
diretta senza programma di montaggio
così effetti speciali va bene
tutto
vai vai direi un bel coppino tirargli un
coppino bravo bravo invece di chiudere
la strada hanno messo una rampa in gta
ragazzo fantastico per saltare con la
macchina
voglio verrà patente subito poiché era
che siamo arrivati al party di youtube
l'anno scorso a questo park io ho
incontrato coeve coop che è stato un
sacco gentile non so se ci sarà qualcuno
adesso non ho idea però noi come ogni
anno speriamo che ci sia dio e con dio
intendo lui però non ci sarà mai
ovviamente però se dio vuole ci sarà
speriamo perché i ragazzi siamo alla
festa di youtube ceco era il corpo di
nuovo talk sa bene le camere
brega tempura è cotto a puntino a una
mia foto nella busta come fosse un
saltino attiva dietro e dinamismo
male
[Musica]
ragazzi siamo una delle feste private di
lei mostrato il suo youtuber preferito
no no per me
io beh se l'open bar quindi puoi
ordinare
a disp
e io ho preso ben due bottigliette
visi vuote e presente l'acqua più
costosa dentro ragazzi hanno invitato
anche gesù che figata
ciao gesù non sono un tuo fan posso
farmi gli effetti con gesù è venuta
perfetta grazie solo i veri youtuber
fanno la botta flip con un'acqua da 7
euro è riuscito a fare il primo
tentativo
[Musica]
ora che incredibile c'è ragazzi ma è
solo della [ __ ] acqua come fa a
costare 33 dollari e solo acqua come fai
acquistare 33 dollari e acqua
[Applauso]
ciao poveri ragazzi siamo tornati in
albergo dopo essere stati alla festa è
tutto la mia fottute 4 più 5 come ci si
sente a bere un'acqua da 10 euro
ciao
[Musica]
dopo tipo 26 volte che sono venuto a los
angeles questa è la prima che vengo
all'osservatorio di los angeles che è
quello che sta sulla collina di
hollywood ci sta vicino proprio da qui
si vede tutta los angeles adesso vi
faccio vedere più o meno come la vista
questo che i ragazzi quello è
l'osservatorio che in teoria anche
abbastanza famoso quindi boh forse avete
già visto da qualche parte e quella è la
bellissima vista di los angeles e quella
è casa mia
quella alta è quella scritta di
hollywood stone bambino la cosa strana
di hollywood e che non ci si può
avvicinare troppissimo la scritta ciao
tesoro
guarda che storia mazzotta ora che è
bellissimo c'è dio santo nostro il
nostro albergo e più o meno grazie
perfetto indicazione utilissima e quindi
ragazzi questo è stato il nostro viaggio
a los angeles generale ovviamente non
registrato tutto quanto ma un bel po di
robbie le cose migliorino registrate ci
teniamo ancora ringraziare nintendo per
averci invitato all'e3 di quest'anno ho
finito adesso di montare pillon si
direbbe mai dallo svegli you me che ciò
addosso
spero che vi sia piaciuto quel momento
mi piace anche i vari social che come
nido trascrizione prossimo viaggio non
ve lo spogliano anche se forse lo sapete
però non me lo spoglio si vedevano
prossimo video beh ragazzi
[Musica]